Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Three: Denmark's sights on the islands.
Now we cross the water.
Kronborg Castle.
Denmark's history is to a great extent marked by the country's location at the entrance to the Baltic Sea.
The shortest way into the Baltic Sea goes through the Øresund.
The town of Helsingør in North Zealand lies where Øresund is narrowest.
Therefore Helsingør has been decisive for being able to control the entry and exit of the Baltic Sea.
From 1429, ships that sailed through the Øresund had to dock and pay a tax, the so-called Sound Dues, øresundstold.
The dues became one of the most important incomes for the Danish king and the Danish state until it was abolished in 1857.
To secure the payment of dues, a castle was built called Krogen, which at the end of the 1500s was expanded into Kronborg, and rebuilt in the 1600s after a fire.
In Kronborg's underground fortress works, called the casemates, sits a statue of the legendary hero Holger Danske.
A well-known myth says that when Denmark is threatened by outside enemies, he will wake up to the country's defence.
Therefore one of the most important resistance groups during the German occupation of Denmark 1940 to 45 took the name Holger Danske.
Kronborg Castle is especially known abroad because it forms the setting of the English playwright William Shakespeare's play "The Tragedy of Hamlet, Prince of Denmark" from 1603, often shortened to Hamlet.
The play is about revenge, doubt and the relationship between life and death.
It is often quoted with the famous sentence "To be or not to be; that is the question".
The sentence is said by the living Prince Hamlet, the symbol of "to be", while he holds a skull, the symbol of death, "not to be", in his hand.
Roskilde Cathedral.
Roskilde Cathedral, Roskilde Domkirke, is regarded as Denmark's most significant church.
The construction began around 1200 and is the first larger brick building in Scandinavia.
Like many other cathedrals of the time in Europe, it is built in the so-called Gothic style, that is, it is marked by pointed, vertical arches that lead the eye upwards towards the sky.
Since the beginning of the 1400s, Roskilde Cathedral has been the Danish royal family's preferred burial church.
About 40 Danish kings and queens, more than anywhere else, are buried here.
Several tombs are placed in rooms that have continuously been built onto the church in the building style of the time.
A visit to the cathedral is thereby also an experience of many centuries of architectural history.
Queen Margrethe the Second's future tomb is in one of the church's side chapels, and here she will one day be buried next to her many predecessors on the Danish throne.
It happens in a sarcophagus designed by the artist Bjørn Nørgaard, who also made the tapestries for the Knights' Hall at Christiansborg.
The tombs of kings and queens in Roskilde Cathedral include King Christian the Fourth, born 1577, reigned 1588 to 1648, and Queen Anna Cathrine, 1577 to 1612, as well as King Frederik the Third, born 1609, reigned 1648 to 70, and Queen Sophie Amalie, 1628 to 85.
Stevns Klint.
The up to 40-metre-high cliff in East Zealand facing the Baltic Sea is built up over millions of years of ancient layers of white-grey limestone, white chalk and flint.
In the middle of the cliff you see a black "line" in the form of a 5 to 20 centimetre layer of fish clay, which is about 65.5 million years old.
More clearly than anywhere else in the world, it tells about one of the biggest natural disasters in the Earth's history.
The ash layer is due to a meteor impact in Mexico, which spread death and destruction all over the world.
Perhaps this is also the reason that the dinosaurs and half of all the Earth's animal species were wiped out.
Højerup Church from the 1200s was built at a good distance from the cliff.
But still some of the church fell into the sea in 1928, because the waves over time have reduced the cliff.
Today the coast, and thereby the church, has been protected from more collapses.
Møns Klint.
Møns Klint lies, as the name says, on the island of Møn in the Baltic Sea.
The high chalk cliffs are under constant change, because the sea eats away at the cliff.
Dronningestolen, the Queen's Chair, at 128 metres, is the cliff's highest point.
Geocenter Møns Klint tells about the formation of the cliff 70 million years ago.
In the sea lived algae with a skeleton of lime.
When the algae died, the lime fell down on the seabed, where over millions of years a thick layer of chalk arose from the lime.
Afterwards the look of the globe changed a lot, as the landmass rose.
And in the ice age the ice caps pushed the chalk together into a giant mountain, which became Møns Klint.
The remains of some of the animals that lived in the sea 70 million years ago, you find today along the cliff beach as so-called fossils.
This applies especially to sea urchins, but you also find, for example, teeth from sharks, and there are also fossils of squid.
To get from the top of the cliff down to the beach you can use the Maglevandstrappen, which at 497 steps is Denmark's longest staircase.
H.C.
Andersen's House, H.C.
Andersens Hus.
In 2021 an entirely new museum opened about the poet and his beloved fairy tales in Odense's H.C.
Andersen quarter.
It is designed by the Japanese architect Kengo Kuma, and the ambition has been to give visitors a many-sided artistic experience with sound, light and pictures.
Via a so-called biographical ramp you come down underground, where the fairy tales can be experienced.
The entrance to the museum is found right by the little yellow house from 1799, where the poet was probably born in 1805.
Hammershus.
The castle Hammershus was built in the 1200s by the Archbishop of Lund in Skåne.
Until the 1500s it was the church that owned large parts of Bornholm.
Hammershus is placed on a lonely rock a good 70 metres above sea level and was thereby easy to defend.
In 1743 Hammershus was abandoned, when the invention of cannons and other new weapons made Hammershus less relevant.
It was afterwards used as a quarry.
That means the population in the local area used its building stones to build houses and other new buildings.
Today Hammershus is Northern Europe's largest castle ruin.
Østerlars Church.
Bornholm is not least known for its four round churches, rundkirker.
Østerlars Church from about 1150 is the largest and perhaps also the oldest.
It was of course a church for local residents, but at the same time it is built as a refuge and defence work against enemies.
Those who defended the church were in the church's upper floors.
The narrow, round stairs and passages made it difficult for the enemies to get up there, at least more than one at a time.
Here is your recap for Episode Three.
From 1429 ships through Øresund had to pay the Sound Dues, abolished in 1857.
Kronborg, at Helsingør, was built to secure the Sound Dues: until 1857 its job was to collect toll, told, from every ship sailing through the Øresund.
It is the setting of Shakespeare's Hamlet from 1603, and contains a statue of Holger Danske; one resistance group in the occupation took his name.
Roskilde Cathedral began about 1200, is the first larger brick building in Scandinavia, is Gothic, and since the early 1400s has been the royal burial church, with about 40 kings and queens buried, more than anywhere else.
Stevns Klint is up to 40 metres high, with a fish clay layer about 65.5 million years old from the meteor impact.
Højerup Church partly fell into the sea in 1928.
Møns Klint's highest point, Dronningestolen, is 128 metres; the Maglevandstrappen has 497 steps.
H.C.
Andersens Hus opened in 2021 in Odense, designed by Kengo Kuma.
Hammershus, built in the 1200s, was abandoned in 1743 and is Northern Europe's largest castle ruin.
Bornholm has four round churches, and Østerlars is the largest, from about 1150.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Where are the most Danish kings and queens buried?
Option A: Viborg Cathedral.
Option B: Roskilde Cathedral.
Option C: Ribe Cathedral.
[DA] Hvor ligger flest danske konger og dronninger begravet?  A: Viborg Domkirke  |  B: Roskilde Domkirke  |  C: Ribe Domkirke
The answer is B: Roskilde Cathedral.
It appeared in the November 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Roskilde Domkirke
Question 2.
In which Danish city can you visit H.C.
Andersen's House?
Option A: Aarhus.
Option B: Odense.
Option C: Copenhagen.
[DA] I hvilken dansk by kan man besøge H.C. Andersens Hus?  A: Aarhus  |  B: Odense  |  C: København
The answer is B: Odense.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Odense
Question 3.
What function did Kronborg Castle in Helsingør have until 1857?
Option A: Home of the Supreme Court.
Option B: Burial place of Danish kings and queens.
Option C: Collecting toll from ships sailing through Øresund.
[DA] Hvilken funktion havde Kronborg Slot i Helsingør frem til 1857?  A: Hjemsted for Højesteret  |  B: Gravsted for danske konger og dronninger  |  C: Opkrævning af told fra skibe, der sejlede gennem Øresund
The answer is C: Collecting toll from ships sailing through Øresund.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Opkrævning af told fra skibe, der sejlede gennem Øresund
Question 4.
Which island is, among other things, known for its round churches?
Option A: Bornholm.
Option B: Samsø.
Option C: Langeland.
[DA] Hvilken ø er blandt andet kendt for sine runde kirker?  A: Bornholm  |  B: Samsø  |  C: Langeland
The answer is A: Bornholm.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Bornholm
Question 5.
Which Danish island is known for its almost 130-metre-high cliff?
Option A: Møn.
Option B: Læsø.
Option C: Als.
[DA] Hvilken dansk ø er kendt for sin næsten 130 meter høje klint (skrænt ved kyst)?  A: Møn  |  B: Læsø  |  C: Als
The answer is A: Møn.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Møn
Question 6.
Which Zealand castle forms the setting of William Shakespeare's play Hamlet?
Option A: Amalienborg.
Option B: Kronborg.
Option C: Fredensborg Castle.
[DA] Hvilket sjællandsk slot danner rammen om William Shakespeares teaterstykke Hamlet?  A: Amalienborg  |  B: Kronborg  |  C: Fredensborg Slot
The answer is B: Kronborg.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Kronborg
Question 7.
On which Danish island does the ruin Hammershus lie?
Option A: Samsø.
Option B: Langeland.
Option C: Bornholm.
[DA] På hvilken dansk ø ligger ruinen Hammershus?  A: Samsø  |  B: Langeland  |  C: Bornholm
The answer is C: Bornholm.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Bornholm
That's the end of this part.
Well done.